ahora que ya hemos clasificado nuestros
elementos en grupos en la tabla
periódica veamos como determinar el
número de electrones de valencia en este
vídeo vamos a hablar del número de
electrones de valencia en los grupos
principales hablando de los grupos
principales estamos usando el sistema de
1 a 8 para clasificar a los grupos
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 vamos a
ignorar la otra manera de enumerar a los
grupos por lo que ignorar hemos del
grupo 3 al 12 en este vídeo cuando
hablamos de los grupos principales los
electrones de valencia son los
electrones en el orbital más alejado o
el nivel de energía más alejado veamos
si podemos descifrar cuántos electrones
de valencia tiene el sodio para el sodio
si quisiera escribir una configuración
electrónica para
el sodio asumo que ya sabes cómo hacer
esto dirías que es
ese 22 s 22 de 6 y eso te lleva hasta el
millón
y entonces eso te lleva al tercer
periodo o el tercer nivel de energía y
necesitas preocuparte solo por un
electrón más y ese electrón irá a el
orbital 3s
la configuración electrónica completa es
1 2 2 s 2 2 3 6 y 3 s 1 cuando quiero
saber cuántos electrones de valencia
tiene el sodio el número de electrones
de valencia sería igual al número de
electrones en el orbital más alejado en
el nivel de energía más elevado el sodio
tiene un nivel de energía dos niveles de
energía y tres niveles de energía el
nivel de energía más alejado sería por
supuesto el tercer nivel de energía si
veo cuántos electrones tiene el sodio en
su orbital más alejado vemos que sólo es
uno esta vez eso significa que el sodio
tiene un electrón de valencia
y eso es muy conveniente porque el sodio
está en el grupo 1
y entonces podemos decir que para grupos
principales si queremos encontrar
cuatros electrones de valencia tenemos
es simplemente igual al
número de grupo
el número de grupo es igual al número de
electrones de valencia y eso hace todo
muy sencillo si quisiera representar un
átomo neutro de sodio con su electrón de
valencia podría dibujar al sodio aquí y
un electrón de valencia al lado del
sodio de esta manera continuamos
escribiendo la configuración electrónica
para el cloro
sería 1 s 2 2 s 22 p
y nuevamente esto me lleva hasta el neón
y ahora estoy aquí en el tercer nivel de
energía o en el tercer periodo puedo ver
que llenar el 3s dos y eso me lleva a
mis orbitales de cuantos electrones hay
en mi orbital p
23 45 así que estoy en el nivel de
energía 3 en los orbitales p y tengo 5
esa sería la configuración electrónica
para el cloro si quiero saber cuántos
electrones de valencia tiene el cloro
tengo que buscar los electrones en el
orbital más alejado en el nivel de
energía más alejado nuevamente tengo el
primer nivel de energía el segundo nivel
de energía y el tercer nivel de energía
quiero el número total de electrones en
el nivel de energía más alejado cuántos
electrones hay en el tercer nivel de
energía tenemos 2 y 5 nos da un total de
7 el cloro tiene 7 electrones de
valencia y nuevamente eso es muy
conveniente porque el cloro está en el
grupo 7 y entonces continuamos dibujando
el cloro con sus 7 electrones de
valencia aquí está el cloro tenemos 1 2
3 4 5 6 y 7 electrones y la razón por la
cual escogí el sodio y el cloro es
porque el sodio y el cloro reaccionarán
juntos para formar cloruro de sodio y
analicemos lo que pasa usando nuestra
configuración electrónica el sodio
perderá un electrón un átomo neutro del
sodio tiene un valor igual de protones
que de electrones pero si el sodio
pierde su electrón de valencia el sodio
perderá su electrón de valencia y puedo
ver que el electrón
de hecho se está moviendo al cloro y
ahora cuando dibujo el sodio tengo que
representarlo como un guión
un cat yo solía tener la misma cantidad
de protones y electrones pero acaba de
perder un electrón por lo que se queda
con un número de protones desbalanceado
hay un protón más que electrones por lo
que puedes decir más una carga de más 1
n a más es el camión del sodio el camión
de sodio es estable y la razón la
podemos ver con la configuración
electrónica resultante si veo la
configuración electrónica resultante
continuaremos utilizando amarillo aquí
sería 1 s 2 2 s 2 2 3
y entonces la configuración electrónica
para el camión de sodio es la misma que
para el neón el cual es un gas noble
sabes que los gases nobles generalmente
son no reactivos y es debido al hecho
que sus configuraciones electrónicas
están llenas en el nivel de energía más
alejado el cat ión de sodio es estable
porque tiene una configuración
electrónica de gas noble para el cloro
si pensamos en cómo reacciona el cloro
el cloro tiene 7 electrones de valencia
y encontremos lo en nuestra tabla
periódica
aquí está el cloro el cloro tiene 7
electrones de valencia si el cloro
obtiene 1 más
entonces el cloro tendrá una
configuración electrónica de gas noble
como el argón entonces el cloro ganará
un electrón continuamos escribiendo la
nueva configuración electrónica si un
nuevo átomo de cloro toma un electrón
más el electrón se añadirá justo aquí en
lugar de 35 escribiremos
p 6
y entonces la configuración electrónica
del año en cloruro será 12 12 22 26 32 y
36 déjame continuar resaltando eso 1 s 2
12 22 63 s 2 y luego 3 p 6 continuamos
dibujando lo ya no estamos hablando de
un átomo neutro de cloro aquí estamos
hablando de un camión cloruro que tomo
un electrón tomó ese electrón del sodio
así que mostraré que ese electrón en
rojo se ha movido aquí al cloro
de esta manera el cloro gana un electrón
solía ser neutro solía tener un número
igual de cargas positivas y negativas
pero añadimos un electrón más eso le da
al cloro una carga negativa y ahora es
el año cloruro tenemos un enlace iónico
entre el camión de sodio y el avión
cloruro la atracción de estas cargas
opuestas forma un enlace
y este es un ejemplo de un metal
alcalino del grupo 1 reaccionando con un
halógeno cierto en nuestro vídeo de
tabla periódica
hablamos de elementos hablamos de estos
metales alcalinos y ya que todos estos
metales alcalinos están en el grupo 1
todos tienen un electrón de valencia y
también hablamos de en los halógenos
aquí
y de que son muy reactivos y la razón
por la cual son tan reactivos es porque
si toman un electrón más tienen una
configuración de gas noble y entonces
dibujando las configuraciones
electrónicas pensando en electrones de
valencia y pensar en la configuración
electrónica resultante te permite
descifrar cómo reaccionan estos
elementos y entonces la razón por la
cual podemos decir que los metales del
grupo 1 son tan no reactivos y de porqué
podemos decir que el grupo 7 los
halógenos son tan reactivos es debido a
este concepto de configuración
electrónica y dibujando a tus electrones
de valencia ahora podemos descifrar
cuántos electrones de valencia tiene
otro elemento más digamos que nos piden
obtener cuántos electrones de valencia
tiene el oxígeno
todo lo que necesitamos hacer es ver el
número del grupo el oxígeno sería en el
grupo 6 por lo que el oxígeno tiene 6
electrones de valencia si quisiera
representar al oxígeno y sus 6
electrones de valencia
puedes continuar y dibujar los 6
electrones de valencia así vemos que es
muy útil pensar en esto si quieres saber
el número de los electrones de valencia
piensa en el número de grupo para los
elementos de los grupos principales